We live in a small solar system in the
suburbs of the Milky Way galaxy.
Eight planets and more than 180 moons, all
orbiting the sun.
In our solar system.
The sun is the sheriff of the town.
We do whatever the sun wants us to do.
The Sun's influence stretches more than one
light year in every direction and defines the
boundary of our solar system.
Someplace out there is a place where the
sun's influence ends and the other star's
begins. That's the entrance to interstellar
space.
Interstellar space is the region between star
systems and our galaxy.
Until now, we've known little about it.
For so long. We've thought of the space in
between the stars as entirely empty.
But this turns out not to be true at all.
There's a lot going on out there, and it's
the forefront of astronomy.
One of the biggest clues about interstellar
space came right to our doorstep.
October 2017.
The Pan-starrs one telescope spots something
unusual.
Pan-starrs is an observatory in.
Hawaii and it's scanning large sections of
the sky, looking for things that change.
All of a sudden there was this tiny little
visitor just screaming through the solar
system. It was going about 200,000 miles an
hour.
It was a much faster object than what might
be expected for a solar system object.
And also its trajectory was such that it
seemed like its orbit was not bound to the
sun.
It was totally unlike any other path, any
other trajectory, any other orbit in our
solar system.
Astronomers reached an extraordinary
conclusion.
It became very clear that, yeah, this was not
some solar system object falling from a long
way away. This was something that came from
another star, and I think everybody was
pretty amazed by that.
Our first known interstellar visitor on a
flyby through our solar system.
It was the very first object that we've ever
discovered that had originated outside the
solar system.
Everything else we've seen, every comet,
every asteroid originated within our solar
system.
Big mega solid object entering in our own
solar system.
And that's something that, you know, I can
only dream of but had never thought it would
actually be a reality.
Scientists name the object Oumuamua Hawaiian
for a messenger from afar, arriving first.
This thing came from interstellar space into
our solar system.
And the main question is what could it be?
The object's shape was mystifying.
It's almost sort of shaped like a cigar.
It's ten times longer than it is wide.
And this is extraordinary.
There's no object in our solar system that
we've ever measured that is this elongated.
Oumuamua looked so unnatural it sparked
scientists imaginations.
One of the things to remember about
scientists is that we're still human beings.
We have read science fiction.
We have imaginations.
I have to admit, when I first heard about it,
my first thought is that it was Rama from an
Arthur C Clarke story, Rendezvous with Rama.
This is a very elongated spaceship that came
from another star.
It reminded me of some designs we had for
interstellar spacecrafts that have to be much
longer than they are wide in order to
minimize friction with the interstellar gas.
Could Oumuamua be an alien interstellar
spacecraft?
Astronomers, including Professor Avi Loeb,
took the idea seriously.
We decided to follow this object using the
best telescopes in the world and observe
whether there is any radio transmission from
it.
Astronomers hunted for signs of alien
communication.
But after eight hours of listening across
multiple frequencies, nothing.
Sadly, no emissions were detected.
It's almost certainly a natural object.
I would bet all of my money on that.
I was disappointed. I would have been much
more excited if we had found evidence for an
alien civilization.
No little green men.
This time a muumuu is a natural object.
But what exactly is it?
At first, observers thought it might be a
comet.
Is something that's mostly ice with a little
bit of rock.
Those are the sorts of bodies that exist
really far out from the star and are the
easiest things to eject.
But a comet passing this close to the sun
would warm up, turning the ice into a gas,
forming a vapor trail.
On a muamua.
Astronomers saw no sign of this happening.
There was no fuzziness around it that you
would expect from a comet as the ice was
turned into a gas.
It was really mysterious.
And so everybody who was observing it
thought it was an asteroid.
As teams track the muumuu across the sky.
There was an unexpected twist.
As Oumuamua passed through our solar system,
it basically was falling in toward the sun,
speeding up immensely as it passed the sun
before exiting the solar system in almost the
opposite direction.
But then something weird happened as it was
moving away from the sun.
It was slowing down as you'd expect, but it
wasn't slowing down fast enough.
A muumuu gets a boost through our solar
system.
But how?
So we think the reason is that it's
outgassing.
In other words, it was emitting a little bit
of gas and that was acting as a little bit of
a rocket motor push on it.
It's kind of like a little jet engine on the
surface.
It just gives it a little thrust over time.
This tiny nudge reveals Oumuamua's true
identity.
So in that case, it is looking more like a
comet.
It's just that that emission wasn't enough
to see.
Powered by outgassing.
This interstellar nomad might travel from
star to star, but figuring out where in the
galaxy it came from just got more difficult.
Now that we know that Oumuamua has outgassed
which changes its velocity and changes its
trajectory, it makes it much harder to do
that.
A muumuu may now be safely racing away, but
the solar system faces bombardment from
another interstellar source, firing at Earth
at close to the speed of light.
Cosmic rays are the bullets of the universe,
and they are flooding interstellar space.